ja ich mache noch ein video zu der
ganzen sache einfach weil ich für nötig
gehalten habe aber bevor irgendein
kommentar schreibt möchte ich auch noch
ganz kurz etwas sagen ich habe auf
diesem video hier keine anzeigen
geschaltet sie wird keine werbung laufen
mit der ich irgendwie geld verdiene oder
so und ich versuche auch so kurz wie
möglich sein und ich werde dieses video
in einigen tagen auch wieder löschen
wenn es die meisten leute gesehen haben
möchte einfach dass er versteht dass ich
dieses video hier wirklich nicht mache
um irgendwie noch mehr klicks
abzugreifen oder mich das zehnte mal zu
diesem thema zu äußern oder noch mehr
geld dann irgendwas zu verdienen so ich
möchte das einfach machen und mich kurz
zu entschuldigen
noch mal ganz kurz meine meinung zu
sagen und dazu komme ich jetzt auch
falls ihr nicht wisst worum es gerade
geht
es handelt sich bei diesem video hier
gerade um eine entschuldigung zu meinem
statement video bezüglich meines war
ofir todesfalls sie dass sie mit bekomme
könnt ihr euch das hier noch mal
anschauen darauf beziehe ich mich jetzt
hier gerade in diesem video ich versuche
mich einerseits so kurz wie nur eben
möglich zu halten auf der anderen seite
aber auch alle sachen irgendwie kurz
noch abzuhaken die ich sagen wollte
ich muss selber eigentlich schon vor 12
minuten in der uni gewesen seien
deswegen will ich sagen ich fange jetzt
mal direkt an ich würde dem projekt
minecraft eur 4 in folge fünf von dem
team ist amor gay muntari getötet und
habe mich daraufhin persönlich
angegriffen gefühlt weil mister morgen
mich bereits in minecraft faro staffel
eins einfach so direkt nach dem start
einfach mit der faust attackiert hat und
ich mich dann halt nach meinem tode
minecraft eur 4 gefragt haben ist am
morgen irgendwas persönlich gegen mich
hat weil er schon das zweite mal einfach
so die ganze zeit auf mich drauf
gegangen ist und hab dann halt ein
statement video hochgeladen wo ich jetzt
ein bisschen dazu verleitet habe ist am
morgen zu helfen
also das war überhaupt nicht meine
absicht ich wollte das nicht ich weiß
ich hab selber in dem statement video
gesagt dass man nicht hätten soll aber
ich glaube das ist nicht wirklich gut
rübergekommen
und ich habe mich dafür auch einfach zu
blöd verhalten dass die leute verstehen
dass man nicht helfen soll also es tut
mir leid falls so rübergekommen ist dass
sich das einzige ziel hatte dass
minister morgan und ari hate abbekommen
so sollte es nicht sein nachdem ich in
der fünften folge nun halt von mister
gay muntari getötet wurde habe ich mir
halt gedacht okay isla morley muntari
haben jetzt ihre komplette fünf folgen
minecraft aro damit verbracht max und
mich irgendwie anzugreifen zu finden und
zu töten müssen morgen hat sich halt
dafür nicht mal gescheut ein streit bzw
jetzt halt den rauswurf aus dem projekt
auf sich zu nehmen weil er als eine
vierte folge im voraus produziert hatte
habe ich mir halt
in der folge gedacht ja gestern morgen
hast du irgendwas persönlich gegen mich
was mich in minecraft warum staffel eins
einfach mit der faust grundlos einfach
die ganze zeit attackiert ohne dich
irgendwie erst darauf zu konzentrieren
vielleicht in welche items zu sammeln
oder abzuhauen und in minecraft faro
staffel 4 hast du mit deiner
teampartnerin halt die ganze zeit nur
damit verbracht max und mich zu finden
und letztendlich halt auch erfolgreich
zu töten und dann habe ich halt dieses
statement video aufgenommen was ich
gestern hochgeladen habe was ich euch
ich wollte dass gerade noch mal von
vorne anfangen weil ich mich so ein
bisschen verhaspelt habe aber ich weiß
gar nicht wo ich stehen geblieben war
wir müssen wissen dass sie ist gerade
der dritte anlauf in dem ich dieses
video hier aufnehme und ich weiß nicht
welche sachen ich schon gesagt habe und
was ich noch nicht gefragt habe ich
komme einfach auf den punkt weil ich
will dieses video auch nicht enorm lang
halten ich bin der oder taschen wieder
bei 10 minuten also ich wollte mich
einfach dafür entschuldigen falls es in
einem statement video so rübergekommen
ist dass ich enorm sauer auf mister
morgi muntari war und dazu verleiten
wollte deren channel zu zerstören oder
die zu hätten so sollte das ganze nicht
rüberkommen ich entschuldige mich dafür
also ein dickes story geht raus an euch
alle mit mister morgen habe ich heute
morgen bereits geschrieben zwischen uns
beiden ist alles cool wir haben
eigentlich gesagt ja wir lassen das
jetzt mal so ein bisschen abflachen
damit dass ein bisschen vergeht mit der
zeit allerdings habe ich mich über die
ganze sache auch nochmal mit max
unterhalten und wir sind dann auf den
entschluss gekommen dass es vielleicht
besser wäre wenn ich dieses kurze
entschuldigung video hochladen um das
einfach mal so ein bisschen gerade zu
rücken hab gesehen dass sehr viele news
kanäle schon videos darüber gemacht
haben so kontroversen ist amor game und
haben halt auch ihre meinung dazu
abgegeben was sie natürlich auch dürfen
ich meine jeder darf seine meinung dazu
sagen und ich habe auch wirklich echt
scheiße gebaut und ich kann auf jeden
fall nachvollziehen wenn einige unter
euch jetzt immer noch sauer auf mich
sind und sagen
luca minecraft osten und projekt sei
noch nicht so sauer wenn du einfach raus
fliegt was soll das denn dass du hier
zum hätten aufruft ich weiß das war dumm
von mir ich bin ein spaß es tut mir leid
ich werde so etwas nicht wieder machen
wenn ich in minecraft war um fünf wieder
dabei sein sollte
ich möchte einfach nur dass zwischen uns
alles cool ist also ich möchte jetzt
nicht dass dieses thema irgendwie unter
dem teppich gekehrt wird und keine
ahnung was ich bin cool mit minister
morgan wir verstehen uns wieder gut mit
max ist alles in ordnung der ist ja
sogar noch ein projekt drin ist am
morgen im steam partnerin aris ja auch
noch im projekt drin also schaut auf
jeden fall mal bei den beiden vorbei ich
arbeite channels und in der beschreibung
verlinkt ich möchte einfach nur dass er
versteht dass mir das ganze wirklich
leid tut und
es war eine blöde idee das statement
video hochzuladen und es war auch sehr
blöd ist am morgen und ari und andere
ware teilnehmer dafür zu kritisieren
dass sie die ganze zeit vor dem pc
hocken und sage ich mal darauf warten
jemand zu töten aber darum geht's halt
in minecraft faro und das habe ich in
dem moment irgendwie nicht so ganz vor
augen gehabt und es tut mir leid falls
sich beleidigend wurde da falls es so
rüber gekommen ist ich möchte dieses
video gar nicht mehr so lange halten ich
will jetzt noch nie noch irgendein
absetzung wieder überlegen was jetzt in
der nächsten szene sage also sorry
entschuldigung es kommt nicht wieder vor
ich hoffe es ist alles gut